Quando uscivo e insegnavo alle mie lezioni, la prima cosa con cui le persone avevano difficoltà erano i biosensori.
Non capivano come qualcuno potesse avere un biosensore al loro interno.
Pensano che debbano essere iniettati.
Pensano di dover inserire un tag RFID.
Pensano di dover sottoporsi a un'iniezione come un vaccino o altro.
Niente di tutto ciò è vero.
Poi il prossimo gruppo di persone dice, beh, allora hanno bisogno di una torre e...
E poi il prossimo gruppo di persone.
Beh, no, devono avere un dispositivo indossabile e tutto il resto.
Perché credi a tutto questo?
C'è una ragione fondamentale per cui il cervello di tutti va lì per primo, indipendentemente da chi tu sia.
Sei tipo, cosa?
No, dovresti mettermi un RFID o dovresti fare questo, quello e tutto il resto.
I biosensori sono costituiti dai globuli rossi, dai peptidi, dalle catene amminiche, dal DNA.
Com'è possibile?
Il tuo corpo è elettrico?
Sì o no?
Sì, ma è solo il mio cuore.
Che mi dici del tuo cervello?
Bene, ok, va bene.
Ma nessuno può vederlo.
Eccoci di nuovo qui.
Il tuo corpo è elettrico?
Sì, ma solo il mio cuore e il mio cervello.
No.
Come fa la mamma a sollevare la macchina?
La bambina e le sue braccia non le strappano il corpo.
Come può succedere?
Eccoci di nuovo qui.
Il corpo è elettrico?
Quindi ho cercato di insegnare alla gente molto chiaramente due cose.
Numero uno, Dio è reale.
Numero due, hai una parte del corpo.
Sono 150 anni su 6000 che non vi lasciano parlare della presenza di questa parte del corpo.
È sempre stato parte degli umani.
Dove è andata?
Ciò richiede riflessione.
Ciò richiede un'analisi, non uno sguardo.
Ho appena...
Non capisco.
No, no, no, no, no.
Sei un adulto.
Tu.
Chiunque tu sia, è compito tuo capire.
Non è compito mio sculacciarti.
Ma sono la tua ignoranza.
La tua mancanza di desiderio o volontà di capire significa morte.
Perché questa è guerra, guerra elettronica.
Questo non lo è.
Entreremo e canteremo Kumbaya.
Stiamo andando a meditare.
Impareremo solo a conoscere i nostri frattali.
Sono uno sciamano.
Mi occupo di energia.
Sto per guarire.
Questa è guerra elettronica.
Ed è per questo che non faccio amicizia, perché non mi perdo questa stronzata con tutti come sono abituati in tutti questi anni.
Beh, non capisco.
È coscienza.
È.
Sai chi?
E tutti ti amano.
Clicca, clicca.
Oh, cos'è successo?
Oh, non lo so.
Sono semplicemente troppo stupido.
Dovrei mangiare dei panini.
Non ne ho idea.
Il corpo è elettrico, vecchio?
Sono andata in ospedale l'altro giorno dopo aver avuto un attacco di cuore a quasi quel bastardo.
Mi è venuto addosso correndo con dei tamponi.
Ha cercato di farmi fulminare come fanno i poliziotti quando sparano ai taser.
L'hanno portato via per sorvegliarlo dall'interno verso l'esterno e ce l'hanno.
O i documenti che sto leggendo.
Non saresti lì.
Quello che è successo a Maui non sarebbe successo per caso.
Oh, eccoci di nuovo.
No, ora sono a casa e questo significa che ho la testa troppo spessa.
Questo non può essere.
Non io.
Smettila di citare la tua rabbia, la tua negazione e la tua incapacità di leggere sugli altri.
Perché non sto parlando solo per me stesso.
Ovviamente, mi sono messo in gioco.
Ma la cosa più grande che tutti noi stiamo incontrando sono gli amici, i debiti della mamma, qualunque cosa possa essere.
Sai leggere?
È semplice come un libro di testo universitario.
Ce ne occupiamo da un anno e mezzo.
La gente preferisce negare.
Ora, puoi dirmi perché è così?
La domanda per il commentatore è, ancora una volta, non prendere in giro le persone.
Il sentimento del commento è ciò a cui mi riferisco.
Come può una manciata di persone controllare tutta la biologia del mondo intero?
Come potremmo osservare tutti gli uragani e tutto il clima e avere il pieno controllo delle condizioni meteorologiche entro il 2025 per la Library of Congress?
Come facciamo a sapere dove si trova la ricaduta nucleare in tutto il mondo con il Dipartimento dell'Energia?
Come facciamo a sapere dove si trovano tutti gli strati del suolo per quanto riguarda tutta l'agricoltura che svolgiamo con iniziative di semina intelligente?
E cosa abbiamo fatto con tutti i semi originali prima di passare agli OGM?
Oh.
Chi ha avuto la responsabilità della tua salute per gran parte della tua vita.
Siete la vostra famiglia, giusto?
Perché se non hai cinque terapisti, sei medici e vai dai medici quattro o cinque volte all'anno, c'è qualcosa che non va in te.
Ok, viviamo tutti così.
Questo è grandioso.
Ma ho fatto un commento lì.
Ho detto, Ehi, solo perché è sempre stato fatto in questo modo, significa che è giusto, soprattutto considerando che l'ambiente è cambiato?
Potrebbe essere stato quattro anni fa?
Perché non c'è alcuna resistenza?
Giusto.
Karen Kingston è andata laggiù per fare causa agli sceriffi per dirgli di non distribuire le nuove foto COVID proprio qui.
E ho detto che era stupido.
Ma ecco perché non capisce il sistema come quello preso di mira rispetto a Garland.
Ma ecco che arriva adesso, proprio ora su YouTube.
Fox News.
Non obbedite.
Va bene.
Non hai detto a nessuno, a nessuno di voi, cose da patrioti, niente del genere.
Non mi hai detto di aver mentito.
E non voglio sentirlo.
So benissimo cosa c'è tra il medico dei media e tutte queste persone.
Wide body area network, c'è il vettore della consegna.
Ecco perché i nostri figli devono impararlo.
La quota di mercato ne sa tutto.
Staremo qui tutto il giorno perché non ammetterai mai come funzionano questi sistemi.
Non vuoi consegnare i telecomandi.
Ora, la persona che mi ha posto questa domanda dovresti chiederti adesso se l'ha sempre saputo, qual è ciò che è richiesto dall'ingegneria, dall'hardware e dal software per raggiungere la portata.
Per rispondere alla tua domanda su come lo stanno realmente facendo, cosa che ho fatto anche tecnicamente.
Ma la prossima cosa da fare, una riflessione critica dovrebbe essere: beh, ci sono un sacco di persone che devono gestire tutti quei sistemi.
Lo so, non è vero, però?
Ti rendi conto di quanti giovani si dedicano a questi lavori?
Il commentatore dovrebbe guardare questo video di reclutamento di operatori di sensori di quattro anni fa e dovrebbe andare su Google e YouTube, Google Biosensors, poi sulla telepatia sintetica.
Quindi il dott.
Cody, quello del Walter Reed con Tech for Psych.
Allora forse inizierai a capirlo a tutti gli altri.
Biofisica, biohacking, ingegneria biomedica, ingegneria tissutale wireless, farmaci wireless.
È quello che fanno nel fine settimana.
Biohacking con Python e Pi che aprivano la porta del garage con la mente, hanno aperto la caffettiera con la loro mente otto anni fa.
Come fanno a controllare la biologia?
Beh, hanno assunto molte persone che non hanno paura di leggerlo.
È qualcosa quando non abbiamo paura di leggere, quando ci fermiamo e facciamo un passo indietro e pensiamo, Ehi, cos'è quello?
Lo voglio sapere.
No, no, no, no.
Non c'è bisogno che tu lo sappia.
È anche per qualcun altro.
No, no, sta influenzando il mio corpo.
Voglio solo sapere, come funziona?
E quando le persone si arrabbiano con te perché vogliono sapere come funziona, ecco il primo passo, bandiera rossa.
Wow, wow.
Ora, tutto quello che ho fatto è mostrare alla gente che funziona così.
Hai notato qual è sempre la resistenza?
Oh, è impossibile.
La mia testa è troppo spessa.
Non capisco.
Come potrebbe essere fatta di me?
Perché il tuo corpo è elettrico e ti hanno mentito sull'anatomia umana.
6000 anni di anatomia umana non sono cambiati quando si strisciava e Blavatsky ha detto: Oh, sì, non esiste nulla tranne ciò che puoi vedere.
L'hanno nascosto in un'università privata.
Università privata.
Paga per giocare.
Volete l'accesso al controllo delle persone in modalità wireless, come hanno fatto per anni le file di cristiani con i nanolipidi.
Ti offro un sistema per accedere e un lavoro da fare.
Non violerai la legge per te.
Non fare mai quello che vuoi o fallo sempre sparire.
Perché?
Perché la gente preferisce negare e mantenere i propri amici e praticare la prevenzione dei conflitti piuttosto che essere sinceri, Ehi, penso che tu abbia rubato una parte del corpo.
Non hai ricevuto una nuova tecnologia.
E questo è l'altro componente.
Da dove viene questa tecnologia?
Da dove provengono tutti i test per quei biosensori?
Scarpa.
Dimmi come.
Stesso problema.
Scusa.
Non puoi sapere come funziona.
Ed è per questo che lo scorso Halloween 107 ha votato Justicia.
Davide Nino.
Mikey Adams.
Cosa ti hanno detto?
Stregoneria.
Dicono di aver paura delle streghe.
E dissi: «Faresti meglio a temere quel bastardo con il cellulare a portata di mano che cammina dietro di te al supermercato, che è quello che abbiamo iniziato a vedere nei video».
Quindi sei ancora pronto ad ammettere che il tuo corpo non è cambiato?
Non è cambiato nulla.
Solo che hai capito che hanno mentito.
Ok, non è colpa mia.
E non è colpa di chi ti ha mandato su questo canale.
Questa è colpa tua.
Poiché la negazione era più comoda, non affrontarla era più facile.
Finché il drone non sarà finito, la tua casa instraderà un segnale di Ebola attraverso il tuo corpo.
Ora, all'improvviso, sono tutti sul mio canale uno e santo cielo.
Aspettate un minuto Questo è un Oh, mio Dio.
Questo è il sistema di consegna.
Sì, è quello che ho detto.
Ho detto, dov'è la telemetria per il sistema circolatorio umano?
Dove è andata?
Se è un vaccino, non è un vaccino.
Se richiede grafene.
Il grafene viene utilizzato per dati e larghezza di banda attraverso la pelle e i tessuti con la nanotecnologia.
Metamateriali.
Cosa stai facendo?
Perché non lo chiedi al professor Ian nel 2013?
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Preferisco negare.
Ai miei amici non piace parlarne.
I miei amici preferirebbero stare qui a parlare della Bibbia, a parlare di qualsiasi cosa la politica prevalga qui e delle interminabili code che non portano da nessuna parte.
Sì, andiamo a parlarne ancora un po'.
In questo modo si gira in cerchio.
Ho un altro segnale che lo attesta.
Questo è il movimento del segnale.
Proteggono i banchieri.
Vai su Wikipedia.
Oh, no, è un grosso arruolamento militare.
Entreremo all'ultimo minuto, uccideremo tutti i cattivi, prenderemo il sopravvento e metteremo Trump in carica.
E ho chiesto stamattina, quindi una volta fatto tutto questo, non credo di averlo pubblicato.
Una volta fatto tutto questo.
NUNBERG Non è successo la prima volta.
Quindi ora lo farai una seconda volta.
La prima volta che è diventato il Progetto Manhattan.
Offerte di lavoro in Project Paperclip.
Sì.
E cos'altro?
Sud America per andare a vivere laggiù e fantastico.
Quindi non è successo.
Ora stai dicendo a tutti che lo farò di nuovo.
Proprio così.
Cazzo, non farai niente per interrompere.
Direttiva del Pentagono 3.000,09 Dichiarazione sulle armi autonome letali.
Esatto, non lo sei.
E quello era il 2017.
È la spina dorsale cibernetica della polizia che richiede non solo tutti quei biosensori che non puoi estrarre da te perché sono fatti del tuo DNA e dei tuoi tessuti, ma richiede anche il tuo DNA.
C'è dentro che si diffonde un segnale che nemmeno conoscete, perché per tutta la vita ve lo hanno detto.
La riserva d'urto prima di passare al campo biologico serve per gli squilibratori d'umore e chi lo sa che non esiste?
Beh, tuo fratello è andato al lavoro, ha catalogato il tuo DNA e ti ha scopato da dietro i muri e lo stalking tra bande, cosa in cui probabilmente non credi nemmeno tu.
Questo va bene.
La stai chiamando con la parola sbagliata.
Si chiama forza di riduzione della firma.
Le dita di Google.
Mettili nel legno per un lavoro e guardali scorrere.
Buoni soldi Sì.
Sono quelli nei furgoni bianchi.
Come il culto dei Finder.
Oh, sono stati arrestati.
No, non l'hanno fatto.
Probabilmente dovresti andare a leggere anche quello.
E poi ecco il.
Oh, abbiamo un film importante.
Stiamo per fare qualcosa.
Non stai facendo niente.
C'è un traffico di organi in corso.
Abbiamo problemi con questi sistemi di guerra elettronica che non servono solo a catturare alcuni aerei, ma anche a colpire i civili.
Vedi, quelle discussioni sarebbero state utili.
Ma hai ucciso delle persone.
Sì.
Dov'è Assange?
Questa è stata la sua discussione.
Mentre Edward Snowden, questa era la sua discussione.
Ancora una volta, ho lavorato con l'hardware che monitorava tutti.
Il mio compito era mettere quel prisma box sull'oc3 sull'o c 24 di AT&T a Chicago.
E i dati di tutti, sono quella scatola chiara e pulita per il backend del dissenso.
Ora, mi rendo conto che forse non avevi un lavoro del genere, quindi hai visto Snowden e hai aspettato.
No, no, no.
Quel tipo fa un sacco di schifo.
Mette in pericolo tutti parlando dei segreti dell'NSA.
Ora, quanti anni fa è successo?
Dieci.
Giusto.
Ok, ora eccoci qui.
COVID dispone di un proprio data center.
COVID una band.
Oh, sì.
Quindi oggi vi ho mostrato il backend del motivo per cui COVID ha la sua rete Wide Body Area per l'Internet of Things.
Quello è lì.
Proprio lì.
L'ho mostrato oggi.
Questa è la tua ragione.
Ora, cosa hai intenzione di fare al riguardo?
Osservatori sospetti.
Sembra che tutti abbiano un rispetto pazzesco per quel ragazzo per quanto riguarda la ricerca sulla sfida a Nassau e tutto il resto.
In uno dei suoi video recenti, ha detto che l'ultima linea di difesa è il tuo campo biologico, la loro parte elettrica del corpo.
Cazzo, perché è influenzata dalla risonanza umana e da tutto ciò che accade di elettrico tranne le persone che continuano a negare.
Perché?
Perché negare?
L'hanno rubato.
L'hanno nascosto.
Non è una nuova tecnologia.
Hanno rubato la parte del corpo, l'hanno collegata al cloud, hanno distribuito telecomandi ai cartelli, ai trafficanti di droga, ai loro amici, al Dipartimento di Stato.
E quando quelle persone volevano che una ragazza o un ragazzo o qualcuno chiudesse la bocca in una causa legale, basta.
Oh, è troppo difficile.
Beh, è così che funziona.
Poi ti prendo in giro più e più volte, chiunque tu sia, e questo ti spacca la testa contro la negazione.
E credo nell'ingegneria biomedica, wireless e tissutale.
È proprio lì, Like, è proprio qui.
E siamo su questo canale più e più volte, non importa quanti documenti pubblicate, non importa cosa dite, le persone intorno a noi, nelle nostre famiglie.
Oh, non ne ho idea.
Ed è stato allora che abbiamo imparato tutti il significato corretto di n d a.
Ho un lavoro.
Non mi è permesso parlarne.
Oh.
È guerra elettronica, quel bersaglio civile.
Era così importante nascondere la parte del corpo e tutta la conoscenza dell'anatomia umana e della fisica dei materiali che utilizziamo.
Einstein deve andare là fuori e mentire sulla gravità.
Tutti sanno che nel mondo della fisica c'è qualcosa di fottutamente sbagliato in quello che dicono per quanto riguarda il modo in cui gestiamo la fisica delle particelle ad alta energia.
Hai fatto quello che sei.
Hai notato l'elenco su quel documento per il monitoraggio e la sorveglianza delle malattie?
Fisica delle particelle ad alta energia.
Proprio così.
Come l'anno scorso durante Halloween.
Oh, è come se ci fosse una corsa agli armamenti per queste equazioni degli algoritmi del DNA bioelettromagnetico.
Proprio così.
Quindi, quando ignoriamo la realtà, mentiamo sull'anatomia umana.
Ogni giorno mentiamo su ciò che facciamo per lavoro.
Cosa succede quando passano gli anni prima che qualcuno finalmente si faccia avanti e dica: Stai mentendo.
Non ci piacciono.
Non vogliamo conflitti.
Oh, benvenuti agli ultimi quattro anni passati a vedere il movimento Q distruggere tutto a causa della recessione di controllo che era stata ordinata.
Eccoci qui.
E lo stanno ancora facendo.
Ecco perché sto dicendo al mio canale che le persone a cui tengo non si facciano coinvolgere in questa stronzata politica.
Orologio.
Il film si trasformerà in cose orribili e vediamo, non è così.
Cosa?
Mi piacerebbe sbagliarmi, ma non sei riuscito a rompere il loro calendario da 6000 anni.
Ho un libro di Michael Syrian.
Fanculo.
Vedi, all'improvviso, ecco il Grande risveglio.
Ok, dov'è la parte del corpo?
Ne vuoi uno minore?
Da dove hai preso la tua tecnologia per la non invasività e per due su tre?
Perché ricordate, non c'era panico satanico.
Sì.
Allora, dov'è la parte del corpo?
Quella che incontrerai.
Perché dov'è la telemetria per la guerra elettronica?
Tutto sta accadendo adesso sotto il comando e il controllo nell'esercito.
Dove si trova?
Sì, ci siamo.
Ho detto parte del corpo invisibile che pensavi di non aver bisogno di conoscere.
Non dovevi preoccuparti di questo.
È fufu.
È figo.
Chi se ne frega?
Sì.
Ora è questione di vita o di morte.
Bel lavoro nel prendere in giro la gente, eh?
Anche tu pensi che sia intelligente continuare a negare qualcosa?
Ora, hai capito?
Chiunque di voi.
Perché sono...
Perché la mia traiettoria si muove?
Perché cerco di rimanere molto concentrato e fermo.
Hai un accordo.
Va bene.
È vero.
Quindi abbiamo un accordo.
Ma le persone lo fanno.
Dicono, no, non può.
Oh, mio Dio.
Questo era ciò su cui contavano Hoover e Dulles e tutti loro.
Ci contano ancora adesso.
E ti accorgi che lo stanno facendo?
Preferisco essere un patriota con i miei magri amici piuttosto che ammettere la rete Widebody.
Scopri come affrontarlo.
Affrontalo.
E poi inseguite persone che so essere pericolose perché mentono ancora al riguardo.
Il che significa che qualcuno ha un pulsante da qualche parte.
Sì, lo so.
È molto più facile stare comodi.
Ok, beh, noi qui sul canale non ci uniremo a voi perché sappiamo che la comodità è la morte, dopo un po' di tempo si va d'accordo e basta.
Andiamo e basta.
Tu.
Quindi.
È proprio accanto.
Quella è nella porta accanto.